hey youtubers is Charlie so a whole lot
of stuff going on in the Walking Dead
universe right now so I'm gonna try and
cover it all in this video starting with
the TV spin-off it was just ordered to
pilot AMC just officially greenlit
Robert Kirkman's Walking Dead spinoff so
I'm gonna do a big update on what's
going on with that and what the status
is I know a lot of you want to know what
it's all about
and why they're even making a spin-off
to begin with and Norman Reedus posted a
potentially spoilery Daryl image to
Facebook and Twitter yesterday so after
the spin-off talk I'll explain what that
was all about hint it's technically not
really a spoiler he's mostly just having
some fun so don't worry no need to freak
out Norman Reedus isn't spoiling season
5 or anything but if you're just finding
me for the first time I'm gonna be doing
weekly season 5 videos so be sure to
subscribe to get everything
I'm even gonna be doing a weekly
giveaway so I might give some game codes
away it might be some gift certificates
but important stuff first WTF is the
spin-off and why have they not been
talking about it more the spinoff is
going to be completely different group
of characters not in or around the
places featured on the main TV show
right now so no Georgia no Washington no
terminus presumably it'll be somewhere
in the United States you know they could
shoot the show in Vancouver as a way to
save money some TV shows do that but
essentially most Walking Dead stories
take place in the United States the idea
of a Walking Dead show taking place in
Europe or China would be pretty freakin
cool though but typically shows like
that big shows especially like Breaking
Bad get their rights sold in foreign
countries and then those foreign
countries have production companies that
make their own versions of the show with
their own characters Breaking Bad is the
best example because they're making a
spanish-language version it's basically
all the same stories just with Spanish
characters in Spanish it's not dubbed or
anything so if you ever wanted to see
what's happening in South America right
now on The Walking Dead universe that
would probably be the way it would
happen like they would sell the rights
in a foreign country and they'd make
another show based on the original
episodes of Walking Dead but with new
actors doing it in their native
languages I know it sounds weird but
that's just the way it happens in TV but
as of right now the spin-off just got
greenlit for a pilot meaning AMC is
gonna pay four or five million dollars
for them to produce a one or a two hour
pilot episode AMC will then either
decide to order it two series and
they'll start shooting episodes or
they'll pass on it and try again for
another spin-off in a couple years
Walking Dead is like far away the most
popular show
has ever had and so most popular show on
cable right now so they really do want
more walking dead if they can get it
there been a lot of rumors about when
the story is gonna take place the
biggest theory is that it would cover
the time of leading up to the virus
outbreak I don't think that's gonna be
the case
but it's one of the better theories it's
more than likely that Robert Kirkman
who's actually working on it himself
will try to capitalize on all the best
things that people love about Walking
Dead and it's not really a show about an
outbreak it's more about survivors
trying to live in the fallout that just
makes me feel like any other Walking
Dead spin-off would be other characters
like that they're not gonna make like a
Walking Dead procedural that would be
more like World War Z with everyone
dealing with the outbreak I think it's
much more interesting to see the
aftermath The Walking Dead telltale game
is a really good example of this you
know it takes place concurrently with
the comics but it's a completely
different group of people and it's been
amazingly popular I think it's given
them a lot of confidence for telling
other stories inside that universe
here's a big question for you guys
though let me know in the comments if it
had to take place in the United States
where would you want the spin-off to be
in a big city or in like another rural
area like Macon Georgia where terminus
is supposed to be or do you totally not
care at all there's this really weird
thing I've noticed in the fandom where
it's like the most popular show on cable
and has this amazing comics and video
game Empire now but there's like a core
group of people that just absolutely
hate Walking Dead like they think it's
totally jumped the shark right now it's
more popular than Game of Thrones but
because Game of Thrones is on HBO and
it's a premium cable channel it's not
really a fair fight just because you
have to pay like ten dollars extra per
month to get HBO but let me know where
you fall in the spectrum do you still
love the show or are you starting to get
tired of it personally I bought my
ticket and I'm gonna ride the train all
the way to Hogwarts or terminus or
wherever you think the show is gonna end
I'm of the opinion that when it does end
though it's gonna be more ambiguous like
a few of the characters will just trudge
on into the distance and try to keep
surviving I don't think they'll ever
find a cure to the virus I mean that's
not what this show is about it's all
about surviving to the last breath
surviving with machine guns that is the
interesting thing about that is that
they have to run out of bullets at some
point I mean this isn't a Rambo movie
where you have unlimited ammo speaking
of unlimited ammo Daryl and his crossbow
were spotted on set Norman Reedus posted
a picture that teases something from the
comics but really I
it's just a misdirect I don't think
you'd ever do something so careless or
stupid is to spoil a big reveal like
actors on shows are pretty good about
that so I'll be talking about Daryl a
lot now but just to talk about these
images he posted potential spoiler
warning I'll just leave this boiler tag
up and you can just skip to you don't
see it anymore everybody ready
okay here we go so normally we just
posted a couple images with Greg
Nicotero on set the first one of you
know Nikki Terrell holding his hand said
I said yes as in you know Nikki Tara was
proposing to him and then in another
picture there's a hand on the ground
with the caption that reads divorced
notice the wedding ring on the hand it
just implies that Daryl got his hand
chopped off obviously everyone went
crazy because of what happened in the
comics with another big character
getting their hand chopped off but
really when you look at the images
that's not the case and when you look at
the first picture this one it's a
different hand than the one on the
ground here so clearly he is just
messing with us just to repeat no I do
not think Daryl is going to get his hand
chopped off I don't remember him ever
wearing a wedding ring and they're not
gonna maim one of the main characters
unless they intend to kill them off
that's a lot of extra energy every day
to get a character ready to shoot
especially for the next couple seasons
because I don't think Darrell is gonna
die anytime soon Hershel is a good
exception to that they chopped his leg
off I think it made sense for that
character because he's not like this
feral warrior that the other characters
are like Rick and Daryl are supposed to
be in season 5 season 5 is all about
action at least the first eight episodes
so yes you know someone's gonna get
their hand chopped off but I don't think
it's gonna be Rick or Daryl what I do
think is gonna happen is some random
person will get it chopped off and it'll
be the show's way of winking at the
comic books without having to go through
the burden of writing around a character
having a missing hand for the next three
seasons okay so suppose over but if we
actually look at the trailer there's
actually this shot of Carl with an
eyepatch I think that's just another you
know wink at the camera I don't think
any big maimings are gonna be happening
to the big characters in the show there
been a lot of rumors about one of them
maybe dying but at this point the show
has diverged so much from the comics I
try not to make huge predictions based
on comic book happenings I think father
Gabriel is probably one of the bigger
things from the comic books that's gonna
make the leap to the show Norman Reedus
just spent a whole lot of time talking
about Daryl in season 5 I feel like he
was
the most interesting characters in
season four maybe a lot of you guys that
felt like he's been one of the most
interesting characters period since he
came on the show but I feel like season
four was a big change for him he was
saying that season five daryl is
basically gonna be a lot more like a
feral cat like a feral cat with a giant
weapon that just sounds like so much fun
it's really interesting to see how his
characters developed from season one you
know originally he was kind of like this
navel-gazing outsider and now he's
really like a fully formed human being
that's part of a group I feel like Rick
retook the leadership role right in that
finale episode but it almost felt like
because of season 4 farmer Rick Daryl
was stepping up to be the new prison
leader even though technically they did
have the committee it's really
interesting to watch the old Daryl
episodes when he was still with Merle
and then watch that Beth episode where
he kind of explains his childhood it
really explains a lot about why he is
the way he is
he had the typical shitty upbringing
like a lot of children of abuse and
didn't turn into the happiest most
social of people and in a way I think
the apocalypse has actually been really
good to him better to him than a lot of
the other characters in order to survive
he's had to learn how to trust people
and how to be part of a group he still
shrugs his way through conversations but
I really do think he feels like Rick's
brother I think he totally believed Rick
whenever they had that talk the morning
after the big WTF claimer scene in the
finale
I don't think Rick is replaced Merle or
anything like that but I do feel like
Daryl feels like the survivors are his
family and his friends now he's not like
that navel-gazing grumpy person from
season one I think watching him learn to
become a normal human has been half the
fun of the character the crossbow really
does do it for me too the crossbow is
where a lot of that fun is I think a lot
of this character development is gonna
stall out for the first half of the
season just because it's gonna be all
about escaping terminus and making the
way to Washington DC I actually thought
they were gonna wait to season six to
head to Washington but it seems that
that might be happening a lot sooner
so Daryl's arc in season five early as
the first half isn't gonna be so much
about integrating with the group it's
gonna be more like Rick's you know just
a lot of ass-kicking for the next eight
episodes I think whenever he lost Beth
he kind of stalled out emotionally had
she not been taken he probably just
would have continued to open up and
start smiling more be like a normal
human being
remember what he looked like whenever
the claimers found him he was just
slumped down in the middle of
and that pile of fail it was like he
regressed completely that's why I feel
like the whole [ __ ] show at terminus is
gonna jumpstart him in a big way like
Norman Reedus said you know you stick
him in a train car he's gonna turn into
a feral cat and what happens when you
open the door he just jumps out with his
claws in this case obviously Claus being
bullets although who knows he could claw
someone's eyes out that would be pretty
badass I think over all the things that
I'm most looking forward to from Daryl
in season five right now is the reunion
with Beth
I feel like he'll finally get some
closure on what happened in season four
and get to continue the path to becoming
a normal human I don't think that's
gonna happen for a long time it's kind
of implied that Beth's story is gonna be
like a side story inside The Walking
Dead universe for at least the first
half of the season but now it's your
turn let me know in the comments below
what are you most excited to see Daryl
do in season five you know besides kill
a ton of people with the crossbow I'm
probably not gonna do a Q&A video for
this just because of korah and Doctor
Who this weekend but now that we are
getting closer to the season five
premiere I'll probably start doing more
bonus videos so feel free to leave me
suggestions for things that you guys
want to talk about my next bonus video
will probably post next Friday be sure
to subscribe to get it
I'll pry start doing some character
videos either like Rick Karl be shown
but feel free to leave me suggestions in
the meantime click here to get my
breakdown of the season 5 trailer and
click here to learn more about some of
the new characters in season 5 thank you
so much for watching I'll see you guys
tonight
high fives